[Musique]
amrita chaudhry a étudié la danse et
l'anthropologie et aujourd'hui elle
enseigne les danses folkloriques et
traditionnelles des différentes régions
de son pays natal vendent
nous l'avons rencontrée sur la rue
jean-talon à montréal mais ici quand on
se promène sur jean-talon même si
j'avoue on peut faire le tour de l'île
de wight
il ya des épées ses délais de pa qui
cette année toutes ces merveilles aux
emplois ici la fin de semaine on a
l'impression des enfants au pays
celle ci a plusieurs c'est voyager ici
on peut venir acheter des badges bonjour
chez vous jam sweet père baisse yasmine
offre des sucreries typique de la banque
aura mais également une spécialité
frites les belges issofa cora avec les
oignons des patates et avec josiane des
peas et je sais juste avec les oignons
et juste les agneaux avec le service
chiche
ok on va en prendre six de chaque wii
[Musique]
plusieurs commerces offrent ces bouchers
frites pour remporter comme en inde où
cette tradition fait partie de la
cuisine de rue
on peut juste aller dans la roue et on
peut acheter ça on peut manger dans la
rue et c'est comme une lunch dans la
ruhr aussi simples comme non fréquemment
un point en face à la maison indian
curie nous avons fait connaissance avec
le ch est arming il qui a bien voulu
nous dévoiler quelques secrets de la
préparation des belges y à l'oignon est
plus populaire au fait un parc de
belgique ou de pâques aura sa dépouille
quelle ville vous venez d un honneur
quelquefois on dit paco là quelques fois
andy badji pas dit ça veut dire juste
quelque chose qui est friquet désunion
coupé et de la farine de pois chiches
auquel on ajoute un savoureux mélange
des pisse du sel au gingembre du cumin
au curcuma et plus encore autant de
saveurs qui nous font voyager
aujourd'hui à préparer ensemble le chef
et moi et le secteur de chef une de ces
crises
il utilise le graines de coriandre ici
et ça donne un petit peu différent
chaque région en est parce que chaque
100 km chaque 150 km le long change la
religion change le visage le cou tout la
musique et la cuisine change
accompagné d'une sauce à la menthe ou au
tamarin on le mange tout simplement avec
les mains dans le gard hérault et on
fait comme ça ici je vais prendre les
deux alors que j'aime tellement cette
texture moelleux à l'intérieur une
traque à l'extérieur les belges y ou
pakora se font également avec des
légumes comme des pommes de terre ou du
chou fleur
normalement c'est comme une boule bleue
des pina vous donnions de légumes
mais aussi avec du poisson une sorte de
fish and chips indienne
c'est vraiment une bonne heure très près
très doux pendant la pub et les gens
mangent ça à quel moment dans la journée
un normalement c'est comme une finale ou
à caen ont pour l'heure du thé c'est
très très populaire après midi en
prendre les paccots là avec indiqué
dans la culture indienne cuisine et ne
sert pas qu'à nourrir le corps allez
quelques mois et le piment à et le
corian le cumin tout te c'est très
thérapeutique pour le corps et l'esprit
et l'âme aussi et quand on cuisine c'est
pas juste on cuisine on utilise la
touche ne semble devoir tous les choses
est plus important avec la mort et le
coeur